we've all relied on entertainers like
those being honored at the tonys this
sunday to bring us joy and keep us sane
during the pandemic well for more than
140 years the actors fund has been a
lifeline to millions working in that
business and not just those on stage or
in front of the camera it also includes
people behind the scenes and that's why
the group recently changed its name and
henceforth will be known as the
entertainment community fund vlad
duterte met several familiar faces to
find out why the fund is so crucial for
the entertainers we all love
if it weren't for the fund i don't know
which direction i would have i would
have wound up twenty years ago actor
singer javier munoz says his life was
upended after an hiv diagnosis i
remember having about three days of
shutting down physically and mentally
and
um really just not
in such shock and then i just woke up
and said you got to take care of you
right so
what are you going to do that's when he
turned to the actors fund for help it
was about getting health insurance about
what i could afford and make work
finding a doctor that could work with
that needing counseling someone to talk
to about the the side effects and what
it feels like they've been in my corner
the entire journey and really allowed me
to
to keep my dignity through
this whole time
munoz who famously took over the iconic
role of alexander hamilton from
lin-manuel miranda now has a lifelong
gratitude to the fun i am living proof
right here that what you do
makes such a difference
and a commitment to spreading the word
it provides the things you know you need
and the things you can't even predict
that you will need
it's beautifully said it comes once a
year
lyricist and composer amanda green says
she's also forever indebted to the
non-profit after it helped her mother
actress phyllis newman as she battled
breast cancer in the 80s at the time it
was kind of something that it was taboo
to talk about she also saw no safety net
for women in the industry
and she founded the women's health
initiative the phyllis newman women's
health initiative so it's really an
incredible arm of the actress fund why
is it important for the folks on the
stage behind the stage
to have this resource it's our lifestyle
right even just being able to pay our
rent and buy groceries it is completely
attached to our ability to work this is
the most unpredictable industry people
rely on the arts and and uh they feed
your soul they they can change minds
they can change lives and hearts but um
we all need to eat too
you know the organization's new name now
reflects all the people it serves anyone
and everyone in theater film television
radio music dance opera and circus
[Music]
tony award winner brian stokes mitchell
has been the chairman of the fund for 18
years
the thing that a lot of people don't
understand about i think show business
is you know you think of show business
you think famous actors and those famous
actors are making a gazillion dollars a
picture and that's not the reality the
reality is most people are gig workers
going from job to job to job and a lot
of people are just
a paycheck away from from poverty
he says the pandemic highlighted the
necessity of this lifeline since the
pandemic has started we have given away
more than
26.8 million dollars to almost 18 000
people now and one of the things that i
realized is
when you're feeling terrible when you're
at your worst
help somebody else
that'll get you out of that a simple
gesture can go a long way like an
impromptu duet with a broadway legend
i'll never forget true dear when i'm
close to you dear the stars fill the sky
so
so that song that we sang
it's called so in love it's from the
musical kiss me kate i played the lead
role in high school and brian stokes
mitchell there i am in my petruccio look
at that
outfit and brian stokes mitchell won his
first tony award for the very same role
so it's kind of cool to be speaking with
a broadway legend and me being a theater
geek kid when i was younger i'm kind of
cool yeah
also amazing 28 million dollars for all
kinds of people in the industry who need
help during the pandemic and i think the
point that he makes is really important
that it's not just the front-facing
people
without a doubt it's all the folks that
are involved in the craft of creating
this art that we know and love